another issue with the browns that uh
is is at least
it's at least
entertaining
although it's still dangerous because
you could get somebody killed when
you're drag racing right left tackle
jedrick wills and receiver richard
higgins allegedly cited for well no
actually cited for allegedly drag racing
let me get that right that was yesterday
morning the attorney says both will
plead not guilty it sounds like
in the city of west lake ohio either the
penalty for drag racing is minimal
or the brown's got a break because
they're browns players and that does
happen in communities throughout the
country who want to support the local
football team it was like 154 dollar
fine which prompted me to say i'm gonna
move to west lake and i'm gonna drag
race that's that's that's that's the
price of admission right that's yeah
that's nothing i'm i'm happy to do that
so uh
there's more to the story and the
attorney
uh again said both will plead not guilty
and wills tweeted that that they are
blowing it way out of proportion so uh
we'll see how that plays out nobody's
ever tried to beat someone off the line
at red light for max 30 meters blowing
away well that is drag racing i i mean
and you can't you can't measure 30
meters when you're trying to blow
someone off the line at a red let's drag
racing jedrick right that's exactly what
it is and and 30 meters is very
questionable too like come on yeah you
can't know 30 meters is nothing nothing
30 meters is basically a hundred feet
you you you you can't blow off the line
at a red light for only a hundred feet
that that is the essence of drag racing
just because you don't see it all the
way through to the end of a quarter mile
or a half mile or a full mile
that that racing away from the red light
is the crime it is the infraction it is
the thing that can cause the car to go
out of control and hit somebody who
happens to be walking by on the sidewalk
it's a dangerous act that's why it's
illegal so
jedrick uh i understand were they in
your early 20s and
and and maybe you think that works but
it did it i ain't buying that jedrick
no i'm not buying that either i mean
first thing i want to say is were they
at the facility together yesterday
leaving there at the same time i i know
wasn't charge you were allowed to get
treatment at the facility even though
it's closed on monday tuesday that's
what i was wondering just
it happened in west lake which is 10
miles away from the facility all right
so they must have been at some some
something listen you know again yeah
it's not a good look i mean
what you're saying and it is dangerous i
mean it's dangerous as hell
um
it's going on listen it it it's it's
entirely possible that they
coincidentally met
at that rate no doubt and they looked at
it and they look and they and they smile
right yeah yeah exactly right and that's
all it takes no exactly young kids young
men with probably nice cars and they're
they yes stupid but having fun not
malice it goes on a lot unfortunately
with nfl football players sorry listen
i
i have done it
the all statues of limitations have
expired i have done it i am willing to
admit it it was a long time ago and the
car was far from nice but i have done it
sure it it's
look it's stupid it's reckless and if
you get caught you
you get caught you deal with the
consequences and you don't downplay it
by saying
it was only 30 meters blowing off the
line at a red light no that's drag
racing jedrick and just just write the
check you guys got the money
and but based on the report from jake
trotter of espn.com they got slapped on
the risk just write
the the the check and move on i don't
think the league office is going to
swoop in with a personal conduct policy
violation over a drag racing citation
and what were you what car were you
driving when you were drag racing i just
would like a little mental image here
well uh well it's not just one car but
still none of them were very nice
the original car was a hand-me-down
volkswagen beetle circa 1973. what color
which
well when i inherited it it was yellow
but i at least persuaded my parents to
pay for it to be painted silver
which there's not much you can do
to make a volkswagen beetle look good
but silver was a hell of a lot better
than yellow
i would say so yeah punch buggy yellow
i'd love to punch you in the arm every
time you drive by that'd be great i'd
love that
then the the next one the next one was
the the the
uh
the ford fairmont which had anything but
a 350 fuel injected dual cam engine
under the hood but
hey you know you still you you you still
put the settlements sometimes when you
put the pedal in the metal it still goes
that's right so uh and it's not like
it's not like somebody had a vet next to
me on those occasions where you happen
to look across and see someone you know
or someone you don't know just depending
upon if the mood strikes you oh look
when you're in that age range
and and you pull up to a red light
yeah sometimes there's there's somebody
next to you even if you don't know who
they are they're in that peer group and
you hear that rev all it takes is that
one rev it's the first rev and and it
kicks in i saw somebody that i'm right
on the way to work
same thing
i knew right away i was like oh this
kid's going to go train drag
he was he was you know before the light
turned green he was already rolling like
and he was halfway through the light and
i was like man he's in a hurry and he
took off and he started weaving through
traffic and everything like that so yeah
i mean you see it every day uh but yes
they probably it sounds like they did
get slapped on the wrist because they're
browns players all that you're right pay
the fine move on don't make it a story
you messed up it's okay it's not a big
deal
yeah because that's the thing the more
that you push it the more that you fight
it because more than people like us are
gonna say yeah wait a minute wait a
minute you guys got slapped on the wrist
for this there should be a bigger
punishment than a 154 dollar fine for
drag racing and we don't even know what
street it was what the posted speed
limit was is it a residential i mean
right you know i i have i have different
feelings about whether or not i'm gonna
wag a finger at somebody based upon
where this kind of stuff happens again
i'm not defending it or condoning it but
i'm a lot more upset about it if it's in
some quiet neighborhood and you got kids
going to the school bus in the morning
and that kind of thing so
that's a factor as well but but but
again
the more that they push back the more
that people are going to want to venture
down the rabbit hole and see what's
there i think they're better off just
writing the check shutting up and moving
on and getting ready for the steelers
game on sunday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports